>>> RIGHT NOW THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
THE SLIMMEST OF MAJORITIES IN
THE U.S. SENATE.
BALANCE OF POWER 50-50 WITH VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HAIRS AS THE
TIE-BREAKING VOTE.
CNN HAS IDENTIFIED THE TEN
SENATE SEATS MOST LIKE THINK TO
FLIP IN 2022.
34 SENATE SEATS IN ALL ARE AT
STAKE NEXT YEAR, AND I WANT TO
BRING THE PANEL BACK WITH ME AND
WE WANT TO DO A LITTLE BIT OF
LIGHTNING ROUND.
WHAT RACE ARE YOU WATCHING THAT
IS THE MOST INTERESTING.
ALWAYS THE CONTRARIAN, J. MART
PICKED THE ALABAMA SENATE RACE.
IT IS A FASCINATING REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY.
>> YES.
>> TELL ME WHY, J. MART, WHEN IT
COMES TO MO BROOKS AND KATIE
BRICK.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE CONTROL
OF THE SENATE NECESSARILY BUT
HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE
FUTURE OF THE SENATE, THE FUTURE
OF CONGRESS, AND WHAT THE GOP IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
THE SORT OF NUTSHELL VERSION OF
THIS IS YOU HAVE MO BROOKS, ONE
OF THE BIGGEST VOICES ON JANUARY
6th URGING PEOPLE TO FIGHT LIKE
HELL IN THE CAPITOL WHO IS IN
THE HOUSE, RUNNING FOR THE
SENATE AND HAS TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT RUNNING AGAINST
SOMEBODY WHO IS A FORMER AIDE TO
SENATOR SHELBY WHO IS RETIRING
WHO IS THE MITCH
McCONNELL-PREFERRED CANDIDATE,
TO BE BLUNT ABOUT IT, MUCH MORE
TRADITIONAL AND MAINSTREAM
CONSERVATIVE.
EITHER WILL WIN THE SEAT IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION, BUT IT'S THIS
KIND OF RACE, PHIL, THAT WILL
SHAPE WHAT KIND OF SENATE THEY
BECOME AND THE GOP BECOMES IN
THE YEARS AHEAD.
MORE OF A DONALD TRUMP PARTY OR
MORE OF A TRADITIONALIST MITCH
McCONNELL AND DICK SHELBY PARTY.
>> AND YOU TALK ABOUT WHERE
TRUMP HAS INFLUENCE ON
PRIMERIES.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT GEORGIA AND
DONALD TRUMP MADE THAT
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE.
IT'S HERSCHEL WALKER, BY ALL
ACCOUNTS RUNNING AGAINST RAPHAEL
WARNOCK.
WARNOCK WON HIS SENATE RUNOFF ON
JANUARY 5th AND PRESIDENT BIDEN
FLIPPED GEORGIA FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE 1992 IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT IN THIS
RACE RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK GEORGIA ONCE
AGAIN IS GOING TO BE THE
EPICENTER FOR THE BATTLE FOR THE
CONTROL OF THE SENATE.
DEMOCRATS SEE THIS AS A STATE
THAT'S BEEN TRENDING PURPOSE.
THEY SEE HERSCHEL WALKER AS A
REALLY FLAWED CANNED DAY.
HE HAS A TRAIL OF ALLEGATIONS
BEHIND HIM INVOLVING PROBLEMATIC
BEHAVIOR AND I THINK STAYS'
ABRAMS JUMPING INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE AND ENSURING
VOTING RIGHTS WILL BE CENTER
STAGE, DEMOCRATS SEE THAT
FAVORING THEM BUT REPUBLICANS
HAVE WARMED UP TO WALKER
INCLUDING MITCH McCONNELL.
THEY WERE IMPRESSED BY HIS FUND
RAISING AND HIS TELEVISION
PERFORMANCES AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT McCONNELL GET
BEHIND WALKER BECAUSE IT AVOIDS
WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A VERY
MESSY CIVIL WAR BETWEEN TRUMP
AND McCONNELL SO THAT'S
ELIMINATED NOW.
I THINK THE BIG "X" FACTOR THAT
I'M WATCHING, NOT JUST IN
GEORGIA, BUT IN ALL THE SENATE
RATIONS BUT ESPECIALLY IN
GEORGIA, IS WHETHER THE
CONTINUED FALSE CLAIMS OF VOTER
FRAUD BY TRUMP AND OTHER
REPUBLICANS IN THE PARTY ARE
GOING TO DEPRESS VOTE TURNOUT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT MOST
REPUBLICAN LEADERS WANT TO KEEP
IN THE REAR VIEW MIRROR, BUT IT
WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHETHER TRUMP CAN RESTRAIN
HIMSELF ESPECIALLY WHEN HE'S OUT
THERE STUMPING FOR CANNED GHAETS
GEORGIA.
>> NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
FRANSCESCA, ANOTHER RACE WHERE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS A WHOLE
LOT OF INFLUENCE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY, NORTH
CAROLINA.
WHAT ARE YOU WATCHING?
>> NORTH CAROLINA IS ON THE
LIST, BUT THE REASON IT'S ON
MINE IS LESS ABOUT WHETHER IT
WILL FLIP AND MORE ABOUT FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
IT WILL BE A TRUE TEST OF THE
POWER OF HIS ENDORSEMENT.
HE'S ENDORSED TED BUDD ALSO
BACKED BY THE INFLUENTIAL
CONSERVATIVE GROUP.
HE'S COMPETING AGAINST FORMER
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF THE STATE
AS WELL AS FORMER REPRESENTATIVE
MARK WALKER IN THE HOUSE.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, TRUMP, HE
WAS PART OF A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO TRIED TO INFLUENCE MARK
WALKER TO GET OUT OF THAT RACE
TO RUN FOR A HOUSE RACE INSTEAD
IN ORDER TO HELP TED BUDD.
WALKER HASN'T DROPPED OUT OF
THAT RACE YET BUT IS CURRENTLY
CONSIDERING T.MEANWHILE, YOU'VE
GOT CLUB FOR GROWTH SPENDING $10
MILLION IN THAT RACE TO TRY TO
BOOST TED BUDD.
WHAT ARE THEY ZEROING IN ON THE
TRUMP ENDORSEMENT.
CLUB FOR GROWTH THINKS IF THEY
CAN TELL VOTERS ABOUT THE TRUMP
ENDORSEMENT WHICH VOTERS MIGHT
NOT KNOW ABOUT BECAUSE TRUMP IS
NO LONGER IN THE WHITE HOUSE OR
ON SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS THAT
THAT WILL ENCOURAGE GOP VOTERS
TO BACK TED BUDD IN THAT
PRIMARY.
WILL THAT BE AN EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY?
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL MAY NOW
THAT THE MARCH PRIMARY HAS BEEN
MUSHED TO MAY.
>> DELAYED, MORE FASCINATING
MONTHS AHEAD.
>> J. MART, I WANT TO GO BACK TO
YOU.
>> YEAH.
>> BECAUSE THE POLITICAL STORY
THAT SHOOK WASHINGTON LAST WEEK
WAS YOUR STORY ABOUT ANOTHER
RACE THAT ISN'T GOING TO BE
COMPETITIVE IN A GENERAL, BUT
WHETHER OR NOT SENATOR JOHN
THUNE, WIDELY EXPECTED TO BE ONE
OF IF NOT THE HEIR APARENTS TO
MITCH McCONNELL, IS CONSIDERING
RETIRING.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW WHY YOU
WROTE IT, AND DOES IT MEAN ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER -- I THINK I
HAD A THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO ASKED
ME WHO YOUR SOURCES WERE ON ON
THAT BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT
MEANS THAT SENATOR THUNE IS
CONSIDERING RETIRING?
>> OH, I THINK IT TELLS YOU A
LOT ABOUT BOTH JUST HOW
DIFFICULT IT HAS BECOME TO SERVE
OF IN CONGRESS IN GENERAL, THE
SORT OF STRAIN, ESPECIALLY FOR
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE NOT THE
TRUMP FANS BUT HAVE TO OBVIOUSLY
SUPPRESS WHAT THEY REALLY THINK
OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT BECAUSE
THEIR BASE MOSTLY STILL LIKES
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
AND I THINK MORE BROADLY IT
TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT THE
CHANGING NATURE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
FROM YOU JUST GO BACK, PHIL, TO
2018, YOU'LL SEE A SUCCESSION OF
GOP LAWMAKERS WHO CHOSE TO
RETIRE RATHER THAN RUN AGAIN
BECAUSE THEY JUST DIDN'T WANT TO
DEAL WITH THE HASSLE OF EITHER
CONTINUE WITH A PRIMARY OR
SERVING IN A TRUMP-DOMINATED
PARTY ANYMORE AND YOU CAN START
WITH BOB CORKER AND JEFF FLAKE
IN 2018, TAKE IT TO THE PRESENT
DAY.
IF THUNE DOES RETIRE, IT WOULD
BECOME THE EXCLAMATION POINT ON
THOSE LAWMAKERS.
JOHN THUNE, ONLY 60 YEARS OLD.
CHOOSING TO RETIRE ON THE
PRECIPICE OF POTENTIALLY BEING
THE LEADER WHICH SENDS A LOUD
STATEMENT ABOUT WHO IS AND IS
NOT EAGER TO SERVE IN TODAY'S
GOP CONGRESS.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT SAID, PHIL, I THINK WE
PIER GOING TO KNOW SOME NEWS
HERE PRETTY SOON ON THIS FRONT
FROM SENATOR THUNE.
THERE'S DEFINITELY FOLKS